bonsoir jacqueline eustache brinio merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
pour commenter ce rapport
les deux inspecteurs qui avait été
chargée d'enquêter sur les jours qui
avaient précédé l'attaqué contre samuel
pâtit l'éducation nationale il a jugé
réactive ce sont ce sont les mots on
avait pointé du doigt effectivement
l'incompréhension de comment cela at-il
pu arriver alors qu'il y avait des
signes avant coureurs notamment ses
vidéos sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
l'alertent de certains parents qu'en
pensez-vous globalement de ce rapport
alors j'ai regardé ce rapport bien
évidemment j'aurais un premier réaction
c'est de guérir comme d'habitude
l'éducation nationale a tout fait c'est
un petit peu le principe c'est à dire
que voilà on est on a tout fait on sait
que voilà on sort toutes les couvertures
et dans le drame que nous avons
collectivement vécu parce que nous
l'avons collectivement vécu ce drame
j'ai juste envie de dire que l'éducation
nationale en tout cas la principale du
collège dans lequel s'est passé ce drame
est la promo m'en fais tout ce qu'elle a
pu
moi quand je regarde exactement ce
rapport je me dis que chacun a essayé de
faire son boulot là où il était mais que
la coordination tout ça afin que cet
enseignant a été massacrée et quand on
regarde ce rapport c'est une histoire
qui a duré longtemps
quand on regarde la chronologie des
faits on se dit mais comment on a pu
laisser traîner cette histoire y compris
même au sein de l'éducation nationale
si vous regardez bien le temps qu'on a
perdue avec ses avec les parents est en
partie du repas en partie la jeune fille
qui a menti et des parents complètement
hystérique derrière elle on a perdu
beaucoup de temps vous avez quand on lit
ce rapport on se dit que un certain
nombre départ en ce concerne comme des
clients
on est au niveau de l'éducation
nationale cirque
il ya des exigences ils sont clients et
l'éducation nationale doit répondre à
leurs attentes de clients s'est passé à
l'école c'est passe à l'école est
vraiment ce rapport
enfin ça c'est que ces conclusions suite
à cette assad ram me laisse perplexe et
me dit que quand même
la coordination entre les services qui
sont chargés du renseignement avec
l'éducation nationale tout ça me semble
extrêmement cloisonné extrêmement
foisonner est que ce professeur on
aurait quand même dû le surveiller et en
tout cas lui apporter une protection
protéger et le protéger et ne pas le
laisser dans l'espace public avec aucune
surveillance
moi j'ai dit dès le départ quand c'est
arrivé que quand on regarde les faits
même avant qu'on ait ce rapport c'était
la chronique d'une mort annoncée
il y avait une telle violence un
acharnement des parents dont celui qui
est en prison aujourd'hui
parce que voilà quand on regarde le
nombre de personnes impliquées dans ce
drame n'a pas qu'une dingue en appuis ça
quand on voit exactement le déroulement
des faits avec ses parents qui ont
harcelé qui ont voulu prendre une place
qui n'était pas là
et puis je veux dit il a quand même
aussi un absent dans tout ça c'est la
place tu la fédération des parents
d'élèves - m'interpelle il ya beaucoup
d'exigences parfois de certaines
fédérations de parents d'élèves pas ils
ont aussi leur place à prendre dans ces
drames et dans cette école qui est
remise en cause par des parents qui au
nom de dogmes et au nom de principes
religieux remettent en cause écoles de
la république
je pense que les fédérations de parents
d'élèves doit aussi doivent aussi
prendre leur place dans ce contexte et
on ne voit pas bien quelles ont été
leurs attitudes pour lutter contre ses
parents complètement hystérique pour
protéger cet enseignant qui n'a pas été
protégé alors justement le rapport
établit 12 préconisations pour éviter si
c'est possible ce genre de drame à
l'avenir vous parlez des parents le
rapport dit réaffirmer le principe de la
liberté pédagogique notamment auprès des
parents ça vous paraît réaliste ça me
paraît une bourse réalise c'est sûr ça
me paraît une évidence et moi j'étais
enseignante c'est une évidence quand
même cirque aujourd'hui rappeler aux
parents il faut leur rappeler
on leur a laissé prendre une telle place
dans l'école que ce soit l'école
primaire l'école et le collège
le lycée ça ce mal qui s'est un peu
moins moins évident mais voilà on leur
prend ils ont un paysan les parents un
mot à dire surtout à voilà le
l'enseignant il a des obligations
ilan hiérarchique est là pour surveiller
qu'il fasse bien son boulot quand il ne
le fait pas bien on lui rappelle et
c'est la règle et c'est la loi mais les
parents n'ont pas à intervenir ni dans
le contenu ni dans la manière dont
l'enseignant fait son travail
si l'enseignant à des comportements qui
peuvent être dénoncée moi j'en connais
pas vraiment mais une fable on parlait
pas à part les parents parce que les
parents estimerait que l'enseignant
maltraite son enfant est à des lieues
pour ça il ya des temps pour ça mais
aussi haute au sein de l'île du cours du
contenu pédagogique et de la manière
dont les enseignants en scène je suis
désolé mais les parents n'ont rien à
dire et ils ont trop dit et donc ils ont
pris une telle place dans
l'environnement de l'école qui a
aussitôt qu'il ya aujourd'hui des
enseignants qui n'arrivent plus à
enseigner parce qu'ils sont en
permanence jugé par des parents qui ne
connaissent vraiment pas qu'ils
connaissent pas le contenu des
programmes et les objectifs par contre
ces mêmes parents seront extrêmement
exigeant si jamais leurs enfants rate un
examen n'arrive pas à obtenir un diplôme
cela on les reverra aussi là qu'on
laisse les enfants les enseignants
travailler et que l'éducation nationale
réaffirme cela et protège les
enseignants au sein de l'institution qui
est l'éducation nationale au carbon bon
nombre d'enseignants aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne se sentent pas soutenus qu'ils ne se
sentent pas protégés et qui sont remis
en cause en permanence par des parents
qui prennent une place qui n'est pas la
leur ça c'est beaucoup trop flagrant
aujourd'hui c'est pas d'hier mais c'est
de plus en plus ce prénom est frappant
au niveau bas de cette institution pour
l autre
autre élément essentiel et c'est ce que
préconise ce rapport la surveillance des
signaux faibles mettre en place une
cellule opérationnelle de veille
surveiller les réseaux sociaux et cela
même au sein du rectorat
c'est la même question est-ce que c'est
réaliste selon vous le problème c'est
que on a un souci c'est que l'éducation
nationale protège l'intérieur ça a
toujours fonctionné comme ça c'est à
dire que bas tout ce qui se passe à 20
ans on rentre dans le collège bah on
protège cette institution sauf que dès
qu'on franchit la grille de l'école et
ce qui se passe à l'extérieur
jusqu'à présent ça concernait - les
choses m'a peut-être qu'aujourd'hui il
va falloir se poser la question c'est
que en dehors du temps scolaire et sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur l'espace
public aussi un aux abords des collèges
aux abords des lycées aux abords des
écoles primaires il se passe des choses
est que les enfants qui sont à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur
ce sont les mêmes enfants il va voir que
chacun trouve les moyens de surveiller
ce qui se passe aussi à l'extérieur du
collège et sur les réseaux sociaux
on sait très bien que des professeurs
parfois craques parce que ils sont
humiliés sur les réseaux sociaux la
réalité là ils sont attaqués ils sont
menacés
il ya c'est aussi un travail qui doit
être fait au niveau l'éducation
nationale et qu'un enseignant qui est
maltraité qui est menacée sur les
réseaux sociaux
même si c'est à 9 heures du soir eh bien
je dois de protéger l'institution va se
donner des moyens alors c'est un vrai
danger ses réseaux sociaux est un vrai
danger et et le lien avec la police il
est essentiel il n'est pas verni alors
ça s'était très tabou aussi un surtout
faites attention faisons attention la
police d'un côté l'école de l1
la police elle a sa place aussi dans la
protection de l'institution dans la
protection des enseignants il faut
ouvrir aussi à l'aller porte à la police
alors ça veut dire que c'est les
policiers ouvert l'école mais jeudi la
vida mans mais sauf que la police elle
doit pouvoir rentrer doit pouvoir
indifférente travail et elle doit
pouvoir être aussi parce que ça aussi ça
ceci elle doit être alertés et on doit
donner les informations à la police
la police elle est là pour pour
préserver la sécurité de tout le monde
des habitants de les citoyens mais des
ans et nous comme des élèves
la police elle est là aussi pour ça il
n'y a pas de tabou à voir on doit aussi
être avec la police vraiment merci
beaucoup jacqueline eustache brinio n'a
pas répondu
en direct ce soir à nos questions sur
rtl france